[Music]
despite apparently covering up
new york's nursing home deaths at the
time governor andrew cuomo
will rake in more than five million
dollars for his book
praising what he did during the pandemic
janice dean lost both of her in-laws
after they developed covid19
in one of the state's long-term care
facilities
and in her op-ed in the new york post
this morning she says
the only place cuomo's book belongs is
under
the true crimes section fox news senior
meteorologist
janice dean joins us right now good
morning to you janice
good morning steve cover of the new york
post it's the big story
people are shocked that he would get
five
five million dollars uh to write this
book
where he talks about what a great job he
did but when you look at it
he didn't do such a good job your
in-laws are dead because of his decision
you
say listen when i first read that the
governor was writing a book in the
middle of the pandemic
i thought it was a joke i thought it was
a headline in the babylon b
or the onion how could the governor
write a book about leadership
when thousands of elderly were dying
it was incredible and i was mad at the
time
but seeing that he got over five million
dollars for this
profiting off the deaths of new yorkers
including my in-laws
it's disgusting and when you look at the
numbers
of according to publicly available
numbers it looks like he sold just
shy of 50 000 books and when you do the
math that means the governor himself
made about a hundred dollars per book
from his book advance when when you
do the math five million dollars fifty
thousand books
that's a deal i've never heard of
it's incredible but i think the book
publishing company can sue him for
breach of contract
because it's filled with lies and if you
look at the timeline
the governor covering up the nursing
home issue
the tragedy over fifteen thousand deaths
that
him and his administration tried to
cover up for months the timeline
corresponds with him trying to sell that
five million dollar book
so i wonder if we can profit off the son
of sam law
all of that money should go to the
families of our dead
loved ones well a lot of the money went
to his family his uh spokesperson put
out this
uh statement to fox news from that net
income the five million dollars
the governor donated a third to the
united way of new york state for
statewide coveted relief and vaccination
effort
for which i believe he did get a tax uh
you know a tax deduction and is given
the remainder
in a trust for his three daughters
equally who worked with the governor
during this pandemic
and did what he calls tireless and
effective work for all new yorkers
and gave him the strength and love to
make it through the crisis
every day but janice you know he would
not have
gotten that lucrative deal had the
actual numbers been out there and now
the more we see the more we realize
it sounds like behind the scenes they
were trying to keep the real numbers out
of the press
so he could get as big a deal as
possible
which he certainly did well i hope
ultimately this book is his downfall and
it's used against him in a court of law
because as i mentioned it's full of
lies so when he goes to court which i
hope he will in
all of the investigations against him i
hope that they use his leadership book
and throw it at him all right janice
dean you can read her op-ed
the pages of the new york post dot com
janice thank you